please welcome from our la studio it's
michaela watkins
hi hi how are you
this diane keaton look that you have
today is so
wonderful and it makes me so happy well
fun fact about this outfit
um i had planned to wear another pair of
pants with it that i premiered the show
with
but i couldn't fit in them because i've
gained weight since the beginning of the
show
because i do think i've gone a little
bit back to stress eating
and i know that song yeah yeah i mean i
literally i could fit in the pants but i
looked
like a sausage that was being stepped on
um so i was like i guess we'll go with
that
other size of that other pant so thank
you
i'm glad you like it because i had like
a horror moment
um i think you look really lovely
and oh thank you first of all i was
watching you
on uh colbert i was uh i'm not exactly
sure when the episode was that you went
outside to
the restaurant across the street what
when was that
it was my first time i went on his show
and i was so excited
because the david letterman theater was
across the street from this restaurant i
used to
be a waitress at and it was really a
miserable time and i used to like
wistfully look at people going
to you know see david letterman and i
would do like the
silverware roll-ups the whole time and
just be like one day
one day and it was a really awful
restaurant like like the management
staff was so
mean and nasty to the to the wait's
death so
i got to have this real um
moment where i got to
go on colbert and then we went across
the street and flipped them the bird is
that
the part you're talking about it's the
greatest thing i've ever seen
but but in fairness i was imitating a
waitress who had gotten
her like a big movie or something like
that and she
came in and flipped us all up and said
i'm out of here so you know what
i think that moment means so much to me
because i feel like
we relate to those kind of moments in
life
not only do we all want to do them we'd
all love to just do that ah
but it's the way you did it that was so
charming
and relatable it's so i just related to
it so much it's how i would handle a
situation
myself and it was so refreshing
to open a studio where people can come
and we can
do this kind of like projection right
where we get them on the hologram and
then we just say
what would you like to say to your
brother by the way
i do think that we could open an online
academy
of you get to go back to places and
times and people in your life
and have that that
yes yes the one that you stay up all
night going
reworking the monologue that you would
have said like in do you remember the
movie tootsie
oh it's the best movie ever the best
movie ever do you remember when
tootsie yells at the boss like it's not
toots or tootsie or honey or baby or
darling it's dorothy capital
d-o-r-o-t-h-y
dorothy it like goes on this whole thing
and we all have that thing where i'm
like
in my mind going i walk over we walk
around trying to be so nice
and then we go home and we're like
here's okay here's what i here's what i
should have no
here's how i should have said it no wait
wait yeah no
this this is what i would have said and
another thing you know
and hey so michaela let's open an online
academy
where you can live out your fantasy that
when you didn't get the moment
to say you really wanted to say
i love this so let's start an academy
of getting that moment back
with total preparation and catharsis
yes oh my god i love this idea i'm let's
should we hug it out yes
let's hug okay come here okay why do i
look like i'm five feet taller than you
i don't know but i i do and then we
merged as one
and now i control you
um you're uh i love this
now you're also playing you know and not
in character
not fully going for it physically but
you know an attractive funny interesting
woman on the unicorn do you like
playing that kind of i do she's sort of
like a toned-down version of some other
stuff i've done because and that's what
sort of the
the challenge with delia on the unicorn
is that she is ferociously loyal and
caring
and i think very codependent with the
people she loves in her life
and wants and controlling wants them to
do well and succeed and
feels that her way is the best way so i
wouldn't
necessarily want to hang out too much
with delia but i appreciate the delias
and and i think that is a balance
because i don't want her to be a
caricature where she goes all one way
where she's just you know
giving marching orders to everybody but
i think she's got i think it all comes
from a place of so much
so much like too much love you know and
i can relate to that
michaela watkins i am such a fan the
unicorn airs thursdays at 9 30 8 30
central on
cbs thank you so much for coming here
thank you so much
yeah one more yeah here we go okay wait
i got to stay over here
i just i'm just wrap my leg around here
we're the same person
i wanted to wrap my leg around you too